uh hello everyone
um so I guess uh so in the next uh of I
guess in this lecture uh what we're
gonna do is that
we're going to bound on random marker
complexity by some uh concrete
uh formula
uh for concrete models
and by concrete models I really just
mean linear models for this lecture and
in the
um a few lectures later we're going to
talk about new Networks and just as a
review to connect to past lectures we
have proved that generalization
error the excess risk of the transition
error is upper bounded by rather Market
complexity that's what we have done last
time although in the last few lectures
and uh in the next few lectures we're
going to talk about how to Upper bound
throughout the market complexity
um for exactly
for concrete models like linear models
or your Networks
so and also we are going to deal with uh
the classification
on loss
so there is something to do uh to to uh
to do with classification loss because
it's a binary loss it's not continuous
so we have to deal with at using some
special technique
so that's the overview for this lecture
so let's first set up the basic things
and classification so we're going to
deal with binary classification
foreign
minus one and one and classifier H which
Maps the input Space X to real number R
so here the classifier maps
Maps the we think of H as the function
that Maps uh the input to the to the
real number the logic for example and
when you make the prediction you take a
sign
um
of the output of the classifier so you
take the sum of H of x
and this gives you the
um the classifier if the H output is
positive numbers you output one and
otherwise you get an active one
and H is the family of H
of H
that's our annotation and the loss
function
on each example X comma y
is equals to the indicator
of Y is not equals to the two exam two
label is not equal to the Sun
of H of x
that's our setup
so
um the
um
right so I guess so
uh the first thing is that I'm going to
very briefly mention this uh final
hypothesis case
as just a
a very quick kind of note or we have
already identified and hypothesis clouds
right so it's probably useful to know
that
um you can recover the same bounds for
finite hypothesis class using this
Machinery of rather Market complexity
right that's a kind of like a probably a
reasonable requirement if you think that
random marker complexity is a powerful
tool so there is indeed such a theorem
which I'm not going to prove today
because the the way to prove it actually
is more related to something
uh more advanced later
um so I'm just gonna State the theorem
so saying that if
F satisfies
that
um
for every F in F
the sum of fzi square
this is
less than M Square
um this is the condition that is a
little kind of like a not super
intuitive but actually what you really
this is saying is that you know this is
implied you know this is a weaker
version
of just assuming FZ is bonded less than
that right
so so if FC is by n then of course the
average of the square is divided by m
square right so it's just I'm assuming
I'm I'm stating the state the week is
the version of the theorem for
generality and if you know this then you
have that
the empirical rather marker complexity
on this example zero up to CN right so s
is equals to
um s is equals to 0 up to zero
right so it is bonded by
the something by the size of this
hypothesis class
and and explained by the logarithmic of
the size of the hypothesis class
something like I'm Square the range of
this function class n function class F
and also you divide by n you take the
square root
so so this is you know essentially
basically it's log F Over N square root
log F over n and and if you apply this
to uh the final hypothesis class that
we'll talk about right for example if
you apply this to the loss function the
binary loss function you get what we had
um
before
um like it's kind of it's almost exactly
the same bounds eventually
so
um and and we are not going to prove
this we are not but we are going to
prove it you know in the future lectures
today we are not going to prove it
because the the techniques is more
related to something what we're going to
use later so
um but this is not a
um you know this is just saying that we
can achieve what we had but it's more
interesting when you apply this by the
marker complexity for a continuous
function class right so and we have also
talked about you know what's the
limitation of uh having fun and
hypothesis class for example the
limitation is that you know if you even
if you do this you know with some kind
of like visualization with continuous
models you're going to lose a parameter
p in your box right so if you do this
plus some discretization
then what likely you'll get is something
like P Over N where p is the
dimensionality of the um of the
model is number of parameters in the
model if you do some discretization so
and it wouldn't be super you know
impressive you know given that we
already have done uh those you know um
Brute Force because visualization that
we had done before
right so
um so today what we're gonna do is that
we're gonna have a different way to
Upper Bound by the market complexity not
using
um this kind of tools and the the way
that we do it is actually more algebraic
and analytical as you see so
um
um so before doing that so uh we are
gonna uh so first deal with the loss
function right so if you look at the
loss right this is l01 x y h right it's
in is this
laughs
so the thing is that the tricky thing is
that there is a sign here
right so if you don't have the Sun and H
of X is outputting something like binary
where we call that we have done this in
one of the previous lecture right so in
that case we assume HX is
so in previous lecture
we have shown that if h x is outputting
something like binary right its outputs
plus one minus one then you can show
that the rather marker complexity of f
the random marker complexity of the loss
functions the losses is basically on the
same order as the radar marker
complexity
of the hypothesis class h
right that's what we did last time but
now we are doing a slightly different
definition of the H right so the H is
the function that outputs the real
number right it's the one that before
the sine function so then uh
um this kind of like a uh this kind of
like reduction doesn't work anymore
right so of course you can still apply
the same thing to the sine of H but then
you're going to get the by the marker
complex stick of the sine of H which you
know again is also it's kind of like you
didn't solve the problem you had a
problem in a different way so so we're
going to express a deal with the on this
issue first and that's called uh
sometimes I think people call it modern
Theory so we're going to introduce a
bunch of tools to deal with this sign
issue in some sense you are trying you
have to convert the real number to the
to the binary number in some effective
way and then we're going to bound the
random complexity of linear models
um and using analytical tools so that's
the uh that's the plot
okay so
um
so I guess the the kind of the intuition
is that
the the scales in some sense like miter
in when you do classification implicitly
but even though at the end of the day
your scale doesn't matter right so so
kind of the the kind of the motivating
example is the following for example
suppose you have a classification task
right I'm using right for positive data
and you have some kind of like
um uh you kind of have the uh you Circle
for the negative data and if you think
about different classifiers for example
this classifier and
uh this one
right so these two classifiers you know
just intuitively I'm not claiming
anything mathematics rigorously if it's
if you inclusive you think about these
two classifiers the the pink one
probably should generalize words
than the blue one because you only see
these eight examples you know maybe if
you kind of like draw a new example test
for example maybe it look like uh maybe
it's here then the pink one would have a
would have a mistake on this test
example right so but the blue one sounds
like less likely to make mistakes on
Test example so
so intuitive play you know like the blue
one seems to have you know some words
better Generation
Um just because it's kind of like
separate the two clusters more clearly
and more confidently so the confidence
or the so in some sense you can think of
this h of X itself as the confidence
right because this is a real number in
some sense this is to the bigger it is
you know the the more confident you are
about this example and and and and and
this doesn't matter to some extent and
this is what we are going to say so like
how do you somehow reason about this and
and make them matter in some sense in
your analysis
um
so so here is the
um the more formal approach towards this
so let's
um firstly Define okay so I guess
let's first assume
this is a assumption throughout this
lecture so we assume that we classify
all the examples correctly so assume the
tuning
ever
is zero
so Perfection perfect classification
fortuning data
and and you can see that this is in some
sense you know reasonable especially
giving them the more than kind of like
on success of the large Network right so
typically you can make the chain viral
very small
um and this was actually a reasonable
assumption even before deep learning
came into play like before deep learning
what people did was that you add more
and more features and to your
dimensionality of the features becomes
Higher and Higher and at some point in
the dimensionality of the features
becomes bigger than the number of
examples and then you can always pay
attention data with zero with zero error
so so formally what that does mean is
that if you look at tuning example it's
always equals to some h of this
that that's what I mean by training our
zeros and under this kind of like
training error zero uh hypothesis class
you can Define the so-called margin
so this margin technically I think is
only defined for at least you know if
you don't do any modification of it you
you probably should only Define it for
zero error classifier and and this is
the so-called unnormalized margin
so and so the margin
of you know X you know this is really
just the Y times H Theta of x
you multiply uh x with Y just because
you know like uh you want to make it a
positive number right so if
Y is positive right if you have positive
class you want h x to be big and
um if Y is negative you want h x to be
small right so so in some sense margin
it's kind of like a a varying form or
informal version of confidence it's not
a probability of course it's between 0
and infinity oh right so this is always
non-active if you fader classifier
exactly on the chaining data so
um so so this is always non-active you
know when you are correct on this data
point right when Y is y and H Theta X
Y is equal to the sine of h x Theta X
okay so this is definition of the margin
of a single example and then you can
definitely Define a margin of the data
set
right the margin for data set margin of
the classifier on the data set so this
is defined to be uh you look at the
minimum uh margin over all examples so
you take the minimum over i y i
times H Theta of x i
of course this model is a function of
the classifier you know if you change
the classifier you have different
margins right in some sense the
the blue one as a a Jew there right like
a has a bigger margin a pink one because
uh in some sense the the pink one has
some example which has very small margin
and the blue one for all the examples
you have big margins so you take the
minimum then over all the examples you
still have relatively big Market
um but I guess you know here I'm
defining an unnormalized margin so so if
you look at Anonymous margin it's not
exactly a distance
from the example to the hyperplane so
you have to normalize it so that it
becomes the distance to the hyperplate
um but I think we
I think in this course we don't need to
actually Define a normalized margin
um per se
um so so if you normally so for linear
model I guess probably you have learned
this from cs299 right so if you for
linear model if you normalize this
margin with the norm of the Theta then
it's going to be the distance between
example to the linear separate to the
hyper plane
um so and and the middle margin would be
the minimum distance of the of all the
examples to the uh to the hyperplate
so and our goal would be something like
you you basically you're going to bond
the generation Our older brother
I guess we bought the generalization I
rebelled by the market complexity
that's what we did in the past but the
rather Market complexity and then this
by some function
of the parameter
and uh the the pirating Norm
so the normal Theta and some function of
the margin that's what we'll eventually
get out of this lecture
so
um and while we need to Define these
margins the reason is that uh this party
comes from a technique to deal with the
loss function
um so so
we're going to introduce a surrogate
loss
function
uh that's texting the margin that takes
the margin into account
I guess you know
we you know at the end of the day all of
this will put will be all together
intuitively the reason we want to do
this is that we somehow believe that
Martin writers follow generalization
then you probably want to have a bonds
that depends on the margin and you want
to have a loss function that also
depends on margin so so far if you you
look at the zero one loss it doesn't
depend on margin right how large HX is
doesn't change your zero one loss on an
example right so as long as the sun
doesn't change you don't really care
right so we want something that kind of
depends on the
um the margin so so the the loss
function is called Web clause
and I think sometimes it's also called
just margin laws
so it's lost function has a parameter
gamma and Gamma is kind of like the
target margin in some sense or kind of a
reference margin you can think of it
like that so this is a loss function
that tips into a single number t
and it outputs
uh maybe let me draw it first
um I guess maybe let's write down the
technical equation
so if T is for the comma okay let me let
me join
so
this function is a function that looks
like this
so and here this is gamma and here
this is one so when
T is larger than gamma you you make it
zero when T is uh
equal to uh when T is less than zero you
make it one that corresponds to the the
the flight area on the left hand side of
the origin and then when you are between
0 and 1 your e linearly interpolate so
this is the way to linearly interpolate
is 1 minus t over gamma if
you are between
0 and gamma
right so so this is the linear region
and and why you are uh why you're
interested in this the reason is that
this is in some sense a
um extension of the zero one loss so
maybe let me first Define notation so
with a bit abuse of notation
you can also write IO gamma X Y you look
at the margin laws applied on this
classifier H that's defined to be
IO gamma y times h of x
this is the definition
so but these two Algoma have different
meanings on left hand side right hand
side as you can see so the this one is
the one we just defined so basically
first of all you know before you know
when you talk about loss functions right
it takes in two arguments Y and Y hat
right so but for classification the only
thing that matters is you take the
product of them so that's why you only
care about y times of H times h of X
right so in the so basically in this
notation
we have know that the ideal loss
function l01 loss function of X and Y
h x is equals to some indicator of
y times h x is
um y times sine of h x
I guess that's the same thing right so y
times h x
is
uh larger than zero right
so this is the this is the zero this is
a different way to write zero one loss
function right so if Y and h x doesn't
have the
wait bye-bye if this is like
Less Than Zero
so
um
so I have to mark that I have a typo
here so that I can fix it for the future
um okay so
um so this is the binary classification
loss and this is the so-called run plus
and you can see the differences is that
the indicator function right would just
look like this
this is indicator T is less than zero
and what we do is that we extend we make
this indicator function more continuous
that's basically what we are doing
so in some so and you can know that so
from this you can see that
the L
gamma y h x is always bigger than the
indicator of y h x
it's less than zero just because
the function above that I do is bigger
pointwise than the function below
right so and which means that if you
look at the zero one loss
of any example
is always less than
the realm Clause at an example
and which means that you know if you
look at the test loss right you do take
the expectation over uh X Y join from p
foreign
so this is the the final thing you
really care about right the
generalization the the test error right
so this is the fundamental thing you
care about you can at least upper bound
this by the population
error under the rug and the population
loss under the Run flaws
right so by doing this you know you
change the you make the the loss bigger
right so which and then we're going to
bound this so so basically with this
eventually what we're going to do is
we're compound the
the test error the test loss under the
Run plus which is the upper bound on the
binary loss
right so so this is our goal upper
boundaries
okay so and how do we up about this
um
so
so I think you know it's kind of
probably you know at least when I read
this you know at the first time from a
book I'm kind of unclear why you want to
do this you know continue continuation
it will come just you know it will come
in a moment so the one of the reasons
you want to make Ellipsis so that you
can somehow on get rid of the loss but
before doing that we have to
um
I guess let's let's first uh clear up
the high level thing first and then
let's look at the low level detail about
how to how to use the laws so the high
level plan would just be that you let IO
hat gamma this is the empirical loss
corresponding to
the
the ramp loss
and you can also Define
[Music]
now I think this is a function for H
mm
we can Define the population loss
as I said is this l l gamma x y h
and then if you use brother marker
complexity
on the Machinery have developed you get
the
population loss
minus the empirical loss
is bonded by two times the
uh the the empirical order marker
complexity plus three times
uh log to the auto over it
right this is what we did in the in the
previous lecture right the
generalization Bond can be the
generalization error can be bounded by
the empirical by the marker complexity
where f is this family of losses defined
by the
foreign
so so this is saying that eventually you
are gonna just uh need to the basically
this will be the the goal next
right because
if you have the bound on the on this
random marker complex that you have the
bound on the
you know we're gonna do this you know
more carefully you know after we have
the right amount of plastic but roughly
speaking once you have the rather Market
complexity you have upper bound on the
population red plots under the
population rate loss upper bounds the
population binary loss
so
um
right
okay
where is the soup
uh sure so yes
um yeah but without soup it's also true
I guess right so um so I guess for
average this is true
okay yeah
uh of with high probability for average
this is true
technical
okay so now let's talk about the the
rather Market complexity so how why
so like
and this review is why we care about the
Run Clause so the rather more complexity
uh
of R of f relates to the random bar
complexity of which in a pretty nice way
and here is the uh here's a lemon that's
released them
um it's called Telegraph
so saying the following so suppose you
have a function Phi
it's a one-dimensional function
and it's Ellipsis for copper Ellipsis
function
all right guys so we have
um kind of Define ellipsis function so
this really means that if you have two
any two numbers Phi of x minus V of Y is
less than Kappa x minus y and here it's
just absolute value because all
everything is one dimensional
okay and once you have this then you can
look at the
composition of this one dimensional
function with any hypothesis cross
so
so this
is defined to be you compose
uh V so basically you might V to the
conversational field of H of
uh the
right so this is the mapping
and this is a
fee will be the loss function basically
but so here is abstract so you can
compose any function V with the
hypothesis class
and to get this feed
composed with h and
uh
anyway so then you can get what you have
so then what you can get is that the
composition
the compose hypothesis class is bounded
by Kappa times RS of H
so so basically saying that if you
compose anything on top of existing
hypothesis class
if what you composed with the fee
function is Ellipsis then you just only
blow up by a factor of copper by the
lips business
so
um and so with this you can probably see
why we care about relaxing the binary
function because the the the the
indicator function is not Ellipsis but
if you use the Run function it will be
lips and that's what we do next so by
the way this this theorem is um this
lemon does
um doesn't have a very simple proof
um we're not going to prove it in the
lecture um
um it does require some it's kind of
like something kind of like pretty in in
my own opinion it's kind of pretty
novel and and deep to me like I you know
I used to be able to prove it but like I
proved it once myself um but I think the
all the existing proofs I know is kind
of like somewhat
a little bit mysterious to me
um
um but but the the high level the
intuition problem is reasonably
reasonable right because you have a
hypothesis cost you compose it with
something that doesn't really introduce
additional fluctuation that much
right so that's why
um that's why you don't make the
hypothesis class much more complicated
um but but if you look at the kind of
like the if you look at exactly what
this formula is saying this is saying
that you take the soup
of age in h so how do you write the left
hand side is something like this right
um Sigma I
uh V of H of z i
and you want to show this is expounded
by
HDI
right that's that's the goal for that
that what this this thing is saying
and look at some will kind of like
imagine why this is difficult to prove
but because
like uh you cannot really change the
order of expectation with soup you know
if you do that you you make the inner
coil too loose and somehow there's a fee
somewhere in the middle of this equation
it's kind of a very hard to period or
period off anyway this is just my
personal comment about this dilemma like
it sounds pretty deep to me oh okay
um anyway so we're going to take uh
we're gonna use this so so and I think
it's probably somewhat
um
um are we obvious how do we use it we're
going to take this field function to be
the Run Plus
right so L gamma of T then because the
Run Clause if you I guess let's go back
to here
so the Run plus is Ellipsis function the
Ellipsis constant depends on gamma
because here the ellipse is constant
zero here it's complete flat so how Loop
just this depends on how was the slope
here and slope there is one over gamma
because this is gamma this is one so the
slope here is one over comma so the
luxiousness of the uh of the red Clause
is a
a v is equals to 1 over gamma sorry
right
so uh and
um if you take
so if you take H to be
I guess let's take H Prime to be this
you Map X Y
to Y times h x
where H is in H
Prime is still not exactly the same as H
because it is a y multiplied with h
and then you take F to be Phi composed
with h Prime
and then by the telegram Lemma
what you have is that the rather more
complex of f which is what we care about
is less than one over gamma
deluxiousness
times RS of H Prime
okay so we kind of get rid of the the
the effect of the loss function by using
this telegram Lemma
and then you can also relate H Prime to
H much easier now because H Prime and H
what's the difference the only
difference is you have a Sime flip by
random marker complexity is not very
sensitive to sound Flip
um this is just because
RS I guess we have done this before
um at least implicitly since some other
proof right so the random R complex of H
Prime is something like this
Sigma i y i
y y i
times h
x i
all right that's using the definition
and now
you look at this Sigma iyi has the same
distribution
is why I
that's our I Sigma I because anyway you
flip it right so so that's why this is
equals to
you can basically get rid of the y i you
get
what's this
and then the right hand side is
the right Market complexity of H
m
okay so with all of this what we got is
that so this basically combining these
two things what we got is that R of f is
less than one over gamma times RS of H
and you can see that the interesting
thing is the first of all the loss is
gone and second Y is also gone right so
you you don't have any wires in the
right hand side anymore
so that's so so basically the at the end
of the only thing that matters now
is the is the is the is the HX
okay so and with this we can put this
all of this thing together to get a
finally let's get the bound on the
binary test error so recall that we
assume
the perfect classification will assume
that y i times h of x i
is bigger than zero for every I this
will assume a perfect fitting
uh perfect
and then you can take
Gama mean
to be
uh
right so this is the
let me see why I'm talking I'm using
yeah
so this gamma Min is the empirical is
the minimum margin uh for
for this data set
right so now
um
you you have that I guess
in technical
let me see what's
I think I have a typo here sorry
so let's just call this gamma this we
use gamma to Define this right so then
if you look at
I'll have gamma h
this is what this is gonna be
I claim is going to be zero because you
have L gamma y i h x i
so n and y h i is always bigger than
gamma and recall that in this run plus
if you are bigger than gamma then you
are zero so basically every example has
zero loss under the ram plots
so for the training example is the
binary laws and the ram Clause are not
different because they are both zero
and
therefore
you uh can have the following sequence
of inequality so you first bound to the
zero one loss of H by the Run Plus
this is because the Run Clause is always
better than larger than zero one loss
and then you say that
uh this is smaller than IO hat gamma h
plus the the rather Market complexity
plus something like of RS
H over
because let's do it a little bit slowly
so this rather marker complexity
of f
is
plus some square root log 2 over Delta n
and then you
use the
inequality between F and H so you get RS
of H
over gamma
plus square root log 2 over Delta over n
and then this one
is zero as we claimed because this is
the empirical run Plus
for the
um for the training data so this becomes
zero so you got just a big O of RS of H
over
um gamma right so comma
so
um
there is a
then the caveat with this with this
inequality I'm not sure whether any of
you have noticed that
um but if you have noticed that maybe
hold down for a second let's first uh
some water interpret
uh
okay maybe let's just explain the salary
so so the problem so there was the
caveat here there's actually there's
actually a mistake in some sense like no
not a serious one but there is a issue
with this you know uh with this
derivation
the reason is that
what is the definition of gamma
right so here the definition of gamma
depends on the data
and then you just mess up all the the
independence all the
like like her so if gamma like when you
do when we do all of these things right
before right so gamma is a constant and
then you have the gamma first and then
you draw your data points you you have
your rather Market complexity so and so
forth
right so but here
we take the gamma to be something that
depends on the data which will break all
the
um the random marker complex Machinery
because in a rather more complexity
machine where you cannot let your loss
function of your function Clause depend
on data right so
Theory
the function class F this cannot be this
cannot
depend
on data
all right so we did want to deal with
the uniform convergence the the H hat
the classifier the final classified Bond
you can depend on data that's the that's
the benefit of uniform convergence but
the function class F cannot depend on
data so that's a small caveat but this
is not a very big deal but but if you
choose okay so but if you choose gamma
to be something that depends on data
then your function cost depends on data
and then you you break this right so
um but I think I'm not going to deal
with this you know very formally just
because this is not a super uh
for mathematical rigors rigor of course
you cannot do this but it's very it's
relatively easy to fix the way to fix it
is that you take another
do another
Union Bond
on the choice
of gamma so for now you choose gamma to
be the minimum uh to be the minimum
margin you know depending on data but
what you should do is you should also
prove this for every gamma
right so if you can prove this
inequality for every gamma this bunch of
inequality this is so first here for
every Gamma or I guess
you can prove it until here for every
gamma
and then in the last type you can choose
the gamma to be the one that you wanted
because you're already done with the
random complexity so so you just plug in
whatever gamma you want right so so I
know and the way to do it is actually
relatively easy roughly speaking what
you do is you say you look at the gamma
as a single number right so to do
uniform convergence over a single
parameter is is always very easy what
you actually here it's even easier
because you don't care about multiple
multiplicative bonds so suppose you have
a bond on what's the largest possible
gamma you have let's say you have B
then what you can do is you can decrease
decrease
into multiple buckets
something like this maybe you can do so
you can serve like one bucket SP over
two over two B another bucket is be over
four to two B over two
and you prove this for every uh
points in this discretization it will
decrease discrete that so basically
within every bucket you don't really
change much right the only difference
between two numbers in the same bucket
is only a factor of two so at most you
lose a factor of two
so basically this is saying that you can
you only have to show
a bounce
for those
points between the like
between each bucket right those kind of
boundary points and how many points they
are they are only log B points
um in some sense and and you can also do
a uniform convergence all of these
points actually gets even
um technical you can even get log Block
B dependency
um but anyway so so this is a
um this is the rough idea about how to
do this last step of uniform convergence
um because it's relatively easy if you
look at the papers I think
um most of the papers don't actually
um don't actually do this step just for
Simplicity of course the state of
theorem in a different way so that it's
the theorem is still correct but so they
just don't do this very very last step
um
um on so to make it simpler so
yeah so that's that's also what I'm
gonna do like I'm not going to prove
prove with you like a
um
a super uh regular theorem I guess you
know if you really want to prove it
what's going to have is the following so
suppose you really want to have a
theorem the theorem statement will look
like this so it will say that with
probability
Delta
for every
um
so for every
gamma between some zero and Gamma Max
then you can say that for every age
L gamma h less than L hat gamma h
plus some Big O of
like this plus square root log one over
Delta Over N plus square roots
log
gamma Max
over something like this
I guess maybe God Max should be larger
than one just to select you
um
and there's a Corollary
you can have l01 H
at for the uh for the for the hypothesis
you care about right it's less than
something like r
of RS of H over R gamma
Plus
curve log one over d
right so here this is the empirical
gamma
maybe I should call it gamma mean I
think I somehow have a little bit of
inconsistent notation here sorry so
this is mean over i y
EP sorry
okay
um
[Music]
but then
so like can we just like I'm 90.1
because
it's like
uh so okay I guess so
uh
I think the question is like whether you
know why you don't take gamma Max to be
really small right
um so first of all it's not clear
whether you can always prove that
the final gamma you have on the
empirical data can be really small
that's probably not actually one gamma
to be big you want to improve the data
to have bigger margin so that your
generalization is smaller
right so you do want to make the somehow
the gamma like at least that's the
interesting regime like this very very
small gamma regime is probably not the
most interesting one because your bond
would be
that your your right hand side will be
very big so so actually if the gum is
really small it's probably probably
don't need the third oh sorry I think
anyway sorry my bad there is a third
term in this as well let me fix that
first
um but so but suppose your gamma is
really very small right so you probably
don't even need a third term because the
first term is already very very big that
correctly kind of like governs your your
generalization ball
so so you do care about somewhat uh
large comma but there's still a question
about why you want to come on
what if all the scales are very very
small right so I think I think it's
really just that um
I think technically you
let me see so
does that answer the question
yeah
um
yeah
I I think there's some kind of like
small things like for example what if
all your everything is super small
right like what if like uh all the
numbers are extremely small I think you
may you you can make this one element
tighter you know in some way yeah
I think there's another question
this one
oh this is log comma Max
and the same thing here
foreign
I don't recommend to spend too much time
thinking about this small facility here
um the the most important thing is to do
the first term right so let's try to so
I guess maybe the interpretation is more
important
okay so the first term this is r as of H
over gamma
right gamma is the agama mean where
gamma mean this is the empirical
margin right of the entire data sets so
and this is saying that if you are very
confident about all the tuning examples
then you're gonna have better
organization your bond will be smaller
right if you're if all the examples are
very very close to be
all the training examples are close to
zero right this is meaning i y i
h x i
right if all the H outputs on your
training examples are very close to zero
that means your gamma Max actually only
involve them in this definition but as
long as one of your
um
example chain example has a very small
age right value has very has a value
very close to zero then your generation
Bond would be
um quite worse
so so you want all the examples to be
very far away from zero like very
constant in some sense
and on the other hand you want your
classifier you want to denominate the
the numerator to be as small as possible
you want your classifier to uh output uh
to to be to be less complex and also
there's another thing to check here
which is the scale does match so the
scaling actually is the rising so for
example we have talked about that
random marker complexity depends on the
scale of your function right so if you
say you multiply all your function by a
half
then your render more complexity will be
reduced by a half
and you can see here that this Bond
makes sense because you cannot cheat by
doing that so if you multiply your
function H sorry
so suppose you say you you have a h
Prime
um which is all the functions
divided by let's say 100 h
right suppose you divide by 100 then
what happens is that the rather marker
complexity of H Prime yes indeed is
divided by a hundred
but the gamma mean will also be divided
by 100. so that's why you cannot see
these bounds you know by a trivial risk
scaling of your hypothesis cause and
that also kind of shows that
something like this will have to show up
here right if you don't have this you
only have RS of H then your bond
wouldn't be right right because your
bond wouldn't be would be wouldn't be
invariant to scale it
foreign
okay so this basically concludes
um with our
um uh treatment about the the loss so
basically the take home is that you have
you care about is two quantity one is
the margin and the other is the random R
complexity
and now let's run the by the marker
complexity
uh for linear models
so
um and then so what I'm going to do is
that I'm going to the linear models
today and next lecture we'll talk about
generally deep learning and from next
lecture we're going to talk more about
like non-linear models in general uh so
I'm going to have first type of overview
for deep learning and then come back to
this to talk about the random marker
complex of non-linear models that's the
that's the high level plan so for linear
models here is a theorem
um so suppose you have a hypothesis
class H which Maps X to
W transpose X
where W is now your parameter unless you
apply measure W has two Norm less than b
then
uh and also let's assume
your data
the data distribution has a
right so this is the L2 Norm square and
expectation is bounded by c squared
suppose you know these two things then
you can boundaries marker complexity
the empirical radar complexity is
bounded by
B Over N Times Square Root
sum of x i
so I guess this is not immediately you
know the scale is in on the right right
the mentioned but I think the the
average one is easier to interpret if
you look at the average
rather marker complexity you can bond
this by B times C over square rooted
so first of all you get this square root
dependency which is very typical for
random marker complexity bound and
second in the numerator you get B which
is the bound of the L2 Norm of the
parameter I also get a c which is
basically talking about how
how large your data it what's the norm
of data points right so you should have
like both of these two things coming
into play because again rather more
complexity you know is sensitive to
scale
so you shouldn't be so you should have
all the scaling things there because
otherwise you can cheat right so like uh
for example what if you don't have C
here then your bond wouldn't be true
because you can scale your X arbitrarily
to make your rather more complex
averagely big
so so you have to have all the scalings
right
so
um
correct so that's the
uh
the first thing we're going to show
about linear models we're going to have
some other theorems about linear models
under other constraints and then we're
going to compare them and also compare
them with the previous Bond as well but
but let's try let's first prove the
theorem
so and this kind of like it also
demonstrates how do you generally Bond
write a marker complexity using this
kind of like a somewhat analytical
approach
so we start with the empirical
um
empirical one empirical number
complexity the definition is that you
draw some
um you draw some sigmas and then you
look at the soup of this sun
and here you write w transpose x i
because this is the model
output
and you take soup over W and the
what's the constraint of w the constant
of w is that L2 Norm is less than b
and
now let's uh do some derivations
so first
so we basically want to solve this soup
first so to solve this soup I want to
understand
what
this thing is right the we realized that
this is actually a linear function of w
and you can write this as
the inner product of w was
the sum of Sigma i x i
this is just because you can pull the
lineage from your front
um sometimes
and now what what's the soup of this
this is easy because
I guess you know
what is the soup of
W inner product with some Vector that's
called um say V
where you take soup over two Norm of w
less than b
right so basically you want to find the
vector that has maximum correlation with
some vector v and you have some constant
on the norm of B right so this is just
literally equals to I guess there are
multiple ways to do this for example one
way to do this you can use caution
shorts
so so you can say WV is less than the
norm of w
times Norm of V
so this is
less than b times
and actually this is this can be a tent
by searching W so the
so the the
answer is that the maximum the soup is
equals to B times the not two Norm of V
and how do you attend this inequality to
attain quality you just choose W to be
on the same direction of V so that your
cautious towards this inequality is
tight
um and and you get the right number
right so I think this is probably I
think this is in one of the homework
questions homework zero question I think
right that's a warm up okay so and if
you apply this you know thing to here so
basically you got B times the vector B
the VA corresponds to this
thing
all right so so you get rid of the six
that's a that's a big thing
first because the soup is very hard to
deal with
and now you have a norm of a random
variable when this random variable is a
sum of
sum of random variables and note that
here we are talking about in paragraph
complexity so the only Randomness come
from Sigma but not X so but still this
is a random variable it's a random mix
mixing of this axis
uh and how to deal with this so we are
going to use uh the
conscious words again so uh I guess
maybe for Preparation let's first get
rid of the
move out the b and Sig B and N so you
get sum of Sigma and x i
pull Norm
uh and you say that this is less than
the square root of the expectation of
the square
this is just because expectation of B is
less than
square root expectation V Square
so uh for any I guess maybe actually
point B for any random variable X let's
say x square X
another thing about you if if you square
the nice thing I think we have seen this
kind of like calculation not only once
um in some other cases we all also seen
this like the nice thing about square is
that you can expand it right so you can
uh you can
um just expand what's inside this
expectation you get
uh this is equals to sum of Sigma I
Square X
I square plus sum of Sigma I Sigma J
X I in a product with x j
this is just the expansion
um
and
then another thing is that this this is
here you have I is not equals to J and
because I is not equal to its
expectation of Sigma or Sigma J is zero
okay
because they are independent variables
you can this is equal to expectation
Sigma I expectation Sigma J which is
equal to zero
so so this term is gone so what we have
is p over n times expectations
sum of Sigma I Square Sigma square is
actually one
because it's rather marker run variable
so x i to Norm Square
and then
the XI to Norm under the expectation is
over Sigma right it's always over Sigma
so the there's no it's equivalent to no
expectation because
x i is not a function of Sigma so we
just have this and this is our
uh desired font
our bound was this exactly this
so so here it appears that you educate
in n in one over n but actually
in this sum you also have something
about n right the sound grows as ungrows
for Infinity so so you balance them you
get actually one over square root and
dependency which will be see more
problems tonight if you do the average
right if you average over X again recall
that
the average number complexity is the
average of in per quarter number
complexity over the randomness of the
data set
then you get V Over N times expectation
over the randomness of s s is the the
concatenate is the the set of X I's
we've got this square root
so now you you get into this exact
situation that where you have some
square root inside expectation which is
not very convenient so you raised to the
higher power that causes shorts using
this thing
so you get B Over N times expectation
of the square of this
I'm sorry I should use x superscript i
right so
and now let's V Over N square root
and each of the X I's has the same
distribution and then we also assume
that this
is equals to I think this is our
assumption C about C right we'll assume
this is equal to c squared
that's the so this is C Square so you
get
um
and C square and you take square root so
you get b c square rooted
right
okay sounds good
any questions
foreign
[Applause]
next I'm going to show another go ahead
[Music]
yes so so this is a this is a great
question the question is that what if
you don't use cautious towards you use
triangle inequality I think I that's
actually a very good question I should
actually actually let's try to do it a
little bit
so
so I guess what you mean here is that
you wait by the way where you want to
use it
once you open like a for example
we are here
um
uh sorry which Yeah Yeah from here to
here basically right yeah so so yes so
that so that's a very good question so
if you don't do this if you say
let me see a different color to indicate
this
so if you say that you do triangle and
quality you're going to bond it by B
Over N times
expectation of the sum of x i
to naught
okay
so then
let's say you also take expectation over
X I just uh or maybe like we don't have
to do that so let's say this is B Over N
times sum of
expectation of x i
x i to know
and let's see what and you can see what
happens here
so you have n terms here and each of
this term is on some constant scale
let's say
and so basically the sum will be on all
of N and then you cancel it with ends
you get B
so basically at the end of that you
don't have dependency on N anymore
so that's that strictly works because we
we do want to have a dependency
something like one over square rooted
that's something that goes to zero as n
goes to Infinity
and the reason is on why this is a loose
inequality the reason is because
here if you look at this this is a sum
of things that can cancel each other
because Sigma I flip things right so and
um
and if you do triangle on the top you
are basically assuming all of these
factors in the same direction
right so so even with the flip right
it's so it's possible that all the
access are exactly the same direction
let's see that's that's already the case
right but with the flip they cancel with
each other right so one of them is going
this direction reality is in the
opposite direction so you have the
cancellation
and and that's why the this conscious
virus is is our distance in the quality
is more kind of like
um height and this is exactly just here
right because you have to use the
concentration cancellation between the
sigma X if you don't use it
actually if you don't use it strongly
enough in some sense you wouldn't have a
have a good bound
um eventually
right exactly exactly
foreign
okay cool and
the next thing would be another theorem
and this different theorem would still
deal with linear models but have
different
Norm measurement of the parameter and
you will see a different Bond and this
is one of the reasons one of the things
I motivated one of the
the reason I use to motivate random
marker complexity because I was saying
that you can get more precise
dependencies on what Norms you want to
use for example
right so so suppose we still have the
same age we have the a different age
it's still linear model but the
constraint on a parameter now becomes L1
naught
so this is L1
and
we'll assume that
now the infinity Norm of x
is less than C
for all I
uh
for oi
and also let's specify the dimension
x i is in Rd
actually this is an interesting thing so
before we didn't even specify the
dimension of X in the previous theorem
because it doesn't show up in the bond
it has to be some Vector in some
dimensions of course right but it
doesn't matter what what the
dimensionality is actually you can apply
this to even
if the dimensional vectors
um as long as the norm of X is bounded
by C so but next theorem will depend on
Dimension the dimension is d
and
then
the empirical order marker complexity is
less than
B times C Times Square Root
2 log D over n
over square rooted
right
and you can see now the norm one Norm
starts to matter you know so so it's
still kind of so let's say suppose you
ignore and ignore the log D so basically
still something like B times C but it's
a different measurement uh on the B and
C the definition are different now the B
is the one Norm of uh of uh W and C is
the infinite Norm of x
we'll compare these two theorems in
after we prove it
let me see
how much time I have
I think I do have time to prove it and
then compare so
um so the proof
the proof won't be
complete in a sense that I have to
invoke some lemon which I will prove
actually
which will be proved by you in the
homework
um
um but let's do the most of the stuff so
the definition is that the same thing
foreign
something like
again
you can view this as some W Times some V
where V is this one over n times the sum
of Sigma I
x i
I'm writing here this is Sigma i w
transpose x y
so we are doing the same decomposition
but now you are taking a soup over one
Norm
and and you know that if you take the
soup off
over one Norm constant B
V times W you can this is also
relatively easy to prove I mean this is
equals to B times
the infinity sorry this W Times V
W Times V this is going to be equals to
the infinite Norm
of B
so so that's how we Island it eliminate
W so we just got the infinite Norm of V
uh
which
let me see
sorry yeah so
let me see what's going on here
yeah I think this is
oh
[Music]
okay
I see so
right so this is going to be equals to
this
however so now we've got a problem so we
have this Infinity Norm
and
so how do we proceed right so you can
for example use triangle inequality
right so then again we don't use the
cancellation right so if you use
triangle like and I'll call it even
flip the you know you swept the sum with
the infinity Norm but you don't have the
cancellation
so how do we deal with this so in some
sense I'm going to uh
uh
kind of like the infinite Norm is kind
of like something
um uh different that you cannot use this
analytical tool so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to do a different approach
or somewhat different approach so from
here so this inequality so
this is a Diagon in some sense so what
you do is that you say you look at what
this uh really means so you can
say that
[Music]
um
the
this is equals to
B Over N times the soup
of
w
is in
sorry
B such as
I think I I probably got the wrong
version of the notes that's why I wasn't
supposed
like a little bit kind of like uh
surprised by the notes because I think
uh on the newer version shouldn't be
like this but anyway so
so the first thing you can do is you can
normalize it to be one so you got W
Times V right that's uh W Bar times V
times B that's easy
and then what you can say is that if you
think about what maximize this inner
product among all the L1 non-bonding
vector actually the only thing you care
about is
so the soup is actually literally equals
to if W1 W bar is between
plus minus E1 plus minus E2 so and so
forth
plus minus e d
this is my claim and and the reason for
this claim is just that you know if you
look at sum of w bar i v i right suppose
I is index for the coordinates right so
how does this is
uh
so basically you can say that
um
so basically you know that the soup
W bar V
is equals to V infinity Norm in notice
um and and what you care about is that
what are the extremo points like in what
case you achieve this uh you achieve
this equality
and it turns out that the way that you
achieved this equality is that W
basically you want to take W bar I
to be one
for I
for I is
the largest entry
so for I such that
v i
is the largest is the max
over VJ
J is in D
right so
I'm not sure whether this is this
probably requires a little bit of a
thinking offline like a
so
um
so so at least you can verify in this
case if you choose wi to be one for this
case and double w i bar to be zero for
all the other eyes then what you get is
that you get sum of wi bar v i is equals
to just v i and VI is equals to V
infinity Norm because bi is the largest
one
uh uh foreign
so if you choose this wi then uh you
and all that all the w i i bar zero so
you got VI
infinite norm and that's equals to V the
the v i in absolute value that that's
the V if they know
right so and and also if if you don't
have apps right or another fans that you
can also flip the Wi on
to be either one or minus one
does it make sense
uh yeah it's not it's it's relatively
easy so it's just a
uh it will probably requires a little
bit of thinking offline as well so so
but the basically is that you know when
you do this kind of like a maximization
over the Simplex you always cut the
vertex right your max the extreme point
is always the vertex that's another way
to think about it and the vertex are
those you know uh natural bases
and then we basically got into a so what
happens is that this is a final hypothe
class
no
what does that mean so basically you can
think of your hypothesis class H bar
is something that X maps to W bar
transpose X where W bar is only
inside this family of
plus minus E1 up to plus minus E
right so so you don't have all the
um you don't have all the linear
classifiers
anymore you just have 2D linear
classifiers now
right so so basically this thing is just
equals to the
basically if you put a b outside you get
this
plus minus EI Public Power V and this is
just equals to B times the random marker
complexity
of this hypothesis cross H bar
okay and we have a claim that in the and
also we can we have claim in the one of
the the very early on part of the
lecture so we claim that for
um
for fun and help us class you can Bond
it by
so this is uh let's go back to the
lecture to the
notes before so this is the Lemon that
we sold the radar complexity is the log
of the hypothesis card size
is bounded by the log of the hypers
class size times something like M Square
where M square is the largest possible
value you can output
from this hypothesis class so let's
complete what M square is right the size
of f is particular is 2D and what's the
what's the so this is equal to 2D but
what is the corresponding m
right so we can say that for every W bar
in this plus minus E I
you know that
you look at the largest I guess you know
that
W bar x i this is back y by
the L1 Norm of w Bar times the L
Infinity Norm
of x i
and this is bounded by
1 times C
right where C is the infinite Norm bond
for x i
and that means that if you look at this
things that we have to verify in the
Lemma
right so we have to verify that
the sum of the squares of the output
is less than M squared right that's what
we have to verify so then because each
of the term is less than this so we can
just
verify the sum of scores this is one
over n times
NC Square
which is equals to C Square
so basically the the corresponding ion
will be just be C square m Square would
be c squared so that's why r as
H bar is less than square root
2 C Square
log side of H Over N this is just the
square root 2 C Square log d
over n
and
now recall that we have a b here which
we got so uh so RS H is less than b
times r h bar which is
uh equals to Which is less than
B times C Times Square Root 2 log B over
square root
okay any questions
foreign
so yeah I think we're about time so I
guess next lecture at the beginning I
would discuss
how do you compare or how do you
interpret these two theorems right so so
these two theorems have their strength
on different cases depending on what
kind of like W's you are what kind of
data you have and what kind of WS you
can fit from the data uh I'll do that in
the next lecture
okay sounds good
um I guess that's all for today see you
next Monday